have I ever told you of the genesis of
my geek rage when I was but a wee lad my
parents were assaulted by a deadly dull
back story I swore then and there to
avenge them my latest beau is the new
film dracula untold which takes Bram
Stoker's book and a few scraps of Slavic
folklore and whips it all into a frothy
hundred-million-dollar blockbuster about
how the famous vampire first became a
bloodsucker sometimes the world no
longer needs a hero sometimes what it
needs is a monster remember that one
flashback scene in Francis Ford Coppola
Stoker's Dracula one where Gary Oldman
is wearing the ridiculous red armor that
it looks like exposed muscle tissue and
he overacts wildly even by his standards
yeah this is a whole movie about that
dracula untold is like one of run your
Kipling's delightful just so stories
except it's not at all doing and it
undermines the mystery of one of
literature's greatest characters fine
jhalak Hollywood get it sure I did there
once again you couldn't once again you
couldn't resist the urge to over explain
you had to suck this intellectual
property dry oh how I wish this
Dracula's story had remained untold it
joins a long list of superfluous flicks
like oz the great and powerful and the
Star Wars prequels go all of which takes
stories we know and love and fills in
the tedious prehistory behind them you
know that wealth of background
information that absolutely no one was
clamoring to hear about
midi-chlorians are microscopic life-form
that resides within all living cells but
the real sin of dracula untold is that
it's just a wind-up it's the first step
in an effort to turn the classic
Universal Monsters into an Avenger style
mega franchise like these iconic
characters need to be established all
over again here's an idea don't lay the
ground works with boring origin stories
don't force us to endure flicks about
wolf man's pimply adolescents or her van
helsings rambunctious college years
instead skip right to the climactic
monster mashup people will camp out for
weeks to see The Mummy Meets The
Hunchback of Notre Dame Meets The
Invisible Man Meets The Creature from
the Black Lagoon meets Phantom of the
Opera and when each monster can only be
on screen for 90 seconds they'll be no
time for backstory as the saying goes
cut to the chase let's make origin
stories history Tate bat died you
monster
what's your favorite universal horror
movie I'm torn between the Spanish
version of Dracula and abbott and
costello meet frankenstein what's your
least favorite origin story I've got to
go with Barry Allen struck by lightning
and bathed in chemicals see that sounds
like overkill let me know you're picking
the comments and subscribe to the wired
channel